Cliff
Neal
kctl
conal the K silent
Nal
nay KET delay talk about a lot of
different things Pastor Cliff connect
Lee Cliff connect Le who has six
consonants and only two vowels in his
last name is a Christian Pastor who
rolls up on college campuses and has
freefor all debates with swarms of
reality challenged
19-year-olds but when Pastor Cliff
showed up to talk to one group of
students he wasn't
expecting Muhammad in the
Bible I brought the evidence that
Muhammad is mentioned in name in Hebrew
and Solomon Song of Solomon and I simply
wish of you to read it out loud Muhammad
was mentioned by name in Song of Solomon
oh I have got to hear this even though
I've heard it a hundred times before and
it keeps getting Dumber every time I
hear it but I have here a verse in the
Hebrew language when it got okay I don't
know how to read but there is you don't
know how to read it I don't know but I
know that the word is there read it out
loud all right it says Muhammad here it
is I don't know how to read it but I
know the word is there and how do you no
because you studied Hebrew no because
you watched some Ahmed D and zachar Nik
videos and you believed what they said
not realizing that they're Compulsive
Liars who would say absolutely anything
to trick people into believing Muhammad
was a prophet fine I'll read the passage
Song of Solomon 5:16 Hebrew you know I'm
going to read it in English for you no
it's not stup the name his mouth is
sweetness itself he is altogether lovely
this is my lover this my friend oh
Daughters of Jerusalem there is no
mention of Muhammad in Song of Solomon
ver 5: 16 why does it say we
mamad did you notice the butterfly
landing on Cliff's Bible as he was
reading his mouth is sweetness
itself Hallelujah
is all together
loveely if a butterfly had landed on the
Quran as a Muslim was reading it our
Muslim friends would be shouting from
the rooftops you see this is the proof
the proof that Islam is
true and as strange as that would be I
have to admit that it would be a much
better argument than Muhammad in Song of
Solomon
5:116 but our friend asked about the
Hebrew
why does it say
muham why does the verse have the word
Muhammad that's the argument by the way
the Hebrew word is a form of mmad which
our Muslim friends assert is actually
the name Muhammad Muhammad mahmad
Muhammad mahmad sounds kind of
similar why would Song of Solomon 516
use the word
mahmad maybe because it's the Hebrew
word for something lovely or desirable
and that's the word the Bride In This
Love poem uses to describe her husband
Solomon Song of Solomon is a short
poetic book about a loving physical
sexual relationship between Solomon and
his bride they go back and forth
praising each other's bodies for
instance in chapter 7: 1-3 Solomon says
to his bride how beautiful your sandal
feet o Prince's daughter sexy your
graceful legs are like Jewels the work
of an artist's hands sexy your navl is a
rounded goblet that never lacks Blended
wine sexy your waist is a mound of Wheat
encircled by LLY sexy your breasts are
like two fawns like twin fawns of a
gazelle
yaza Solomon Praises her body a lot and
she Praises his body a lot in Song of
Solomon 5 after praising his body part
by part she concludes by saying he is
altogether lovely our Muslim friends
tell us that the word lovely here is the
name Muhammad so the verse should be
translated he is altogether
Muhammad sadly Cliff just isn't
interested in playing this game and is
not talking about an historical Mohamed
it's not even referring to him sir
you're playing a little semantic game
it's not you want to play a game we'll
go play basketball okay I'm not out here
to play semantic you refuse to look at
it but our Muslim friend points out that
if Cliff simply understood the Hebrew he
would see Muhammad there the name
Muhammad is means the one who is
altogether lovely which is the thing
that you read but then when you
translate the name Muhammad to all
together you miss the name Muhammad if
you became the Masters in in the bibl
religion you will never recognize it was
Muhammad because the name was taken that
Masters in it do you Masters in it he
said the name Muhammad means altogether
lovely it doesn't the Arabic name
Muhammad means
praiseworthy the word in Song of Solomon
5:116 is mmad which means lovely or
desirable think about this there's an
Arabic name Muhammad
there's a Hebrew word mahmad that's used
about a dozen times in the Old Testament
the words sound somewhat similar and
Muslims argue that since they sound
similar they're actually referring to
the same thing we call this the phonic
fallacy you commit the phonic fallacy
when you say that two words in two
different languages sound alike and
therefore mean the same thing
Hebrew and Arabic are different
languages our Muslim friends claim that
since the word mahmad sounds like the
word Muhammad it's really the same word
if that's their theory of language we
can prove all kinds of fun things about
Islam for example many Muslims shout
Allah abbar in various situations in
Arabic Allahu Akbar means God is greater
Allahu Allah is Akbar greater makes
perfect sense in Arabic but since our
Muslim friends apparently believe that
Hebrew and Arabic words that sound alike
are really the same word we can finally
understand what Muslims are really
saying when they shout Allahu
abbar the Arabic word Akbar meaning
greater sounds a lot like the Hebrew
word Akbar which means
Mouse so according to our Muslim friends
when they Shout allahar bar they're
actually shouting Allah is a mouse now
if they don't want us to believe that
they worship a mouse they're going to
have to drop the idea that a Hebrew word
that sounds similar to an Arabic word
must refer to the same thing but if they
drop that idea there goes their argument
from Song of Solomon
5:16 as Pastor Cliff concludes Muslims
need to come up with something better
than this you you got to learn to defend
your faith better than stringing some
words that don't mean Muhammad and
acting like they do that's talking about
a lover in a love poem The Song of
Solomon Cliff points out that Song of
Solomon is a love poem it is in fact if
we want to lay this argument to rest in
Islam's Cemetery of absurd arguments
right between the argument from the
perfect preservation of the Quran and
the argument from scientific Miracles
all we need need to do is read the
chapter and see if the Muslim
interpretation makes any sense
whatsoever here goes Song of Solomon
Chapter
5 this is Solomon speaking but since our
Muslim friends think the bride is
talking about Muhammad this would
actually be Muhammad according to them
he says I have come into my garden my
sister my bride I have gathered my myrrh
with my spice I have eaten my honeycomb
and my honey I have drunk my wine and my
milk uh-oh Muhammad was drinking wine
hypocrite and here we have the friends
who say eat friends and drink drink your
fill of love and the bride says I slept
but my heart was awake listen my beloved
is knocking open to me my sister my
darling my Dove my Flawless one my head
is is drenched with Dew my hair with the
dampness of the night I have taken off
my robe must I put it on again I have
washed my feet must I soil them again my
beloved thrust his hand through the
latch opening my heart began to pound
for him I arose to open for my beloved
and my hands dripped with myrr my
fingers with flowing myrr on the handles
of the bolt I opened for my beloved but
my beloved had left he was gone my heart
sank at his departure I looked for him
but did not find him I called him but he
did not answer the Watchmen found me as
they made their rounds in the city they
beat me they bruised me they took away
my cloak those Watchmen of the walls
Daughters of Jerusalem I charge you if
you find my beloved what will you tell
him tell him I am faint with love love
for whom for Solomon her husband or for
Muhammad a fake Prophet who would
wouldn't be born for about another 1,500
years the friends ask how is your
beloved better than others most
beautiful of women how is your beloved
better than others that you so charge us
what makes your beloved so special she
replies my beloved is radiant and Ruddy
outstanding among 10,000 his head is
purest gold his hair is wavy and black
as a raven his eyes are like doves by
the water streams washed in milk mounted
like Jewels his cheeks are like beds of
spice yielding perfume his lips are like
lies dripping with myrr his arms are
rods of gold set with topaz his body is
like polished Ivory decorated with lapis
lazuli his legs are pillars of marble
set on bases of gold his appearance is
like Lebanon Choice as its Cedars his
mouth is sweet itself he is alog
together
Muhammad this is my beloved this is my
friend Daughters of
Jerusalem seems like altogether lovely
would make perfect sense since she just
described his body part by part but daag
gists insist that mahmad is the name
Muhammad and that Solomon's wife was
some sort of propheus with an adulterous
mind who was lusting after Muhammad's
hot
b500 years before he was
born so are you convinced by one of the
most popular Arguments for Muhammad in
the Bible are you convinced that
Solomon's wife was in love with Muhammad
and that the Song of Solomon is a book
of love poetry between Muhammad and a
woman who had been dead for 15
centuries or are you convinced that dawa
is the most embarrassingly idiotic
nonsense the world has ever
seen share your thoughts on this
arguments in the comments section
[Music]